Oi
bom dia
alguns de vocês já já Alguém já reparou
ao pormenor nos tetos do Café do café
Majestic que é um ex-líbris aqui do
porto ou dos textos fantásticos do
Palacete das Águias ou até do mais
recente Palácio restaurado ou Palácio do
Conde de bilhão
ao pormenor
parar e olhar ao pormenor
eu confesse que até uns anos atrás
eles passavam despercebidos Eu costumo
contar uma história eu estudei em
belas-artes aqui no porto e vive numa
casa que tinha os tectos estucados e o
meu quarto tem um teto incrível e E
lembramos uma de uma forma circular
é
repleta recheada de flores e houve um
dia típico nas casas do porto Castores
incríveis infiltrações no teto ruiu
parte do teto ruiu
a solução que o que o
que o senhorio encontrou foi
deitar tudo abaixo e por liso
E
nesta situação que mais me entristece
nem era questão do por liso Eu
compreendo que isso tem os teus custos o
que mais me entristece mesmo é que não
há o único registo deste teto eu dormi
meses naquele quarto e não há sequer um
olho que o registo de assistir um teto
que realmente único que representa uma
época representa o gosto pessoal do
cliente que construiu aquele Edifício e
não a
este este meu esta minha dor entre aspas
despertou quando depois de ter terminado
a faculdade de belas-artes ingressei
numa empresa estrangeira
especializada em gessos decorativos aí
eu tive a oportunidade de trabalhar com
senhores estucadores que me o que me
ensinaram imenso Já devia ter passado
Isto é bom
e que me ensinaram que me ensinaram
imenso vamos agora ver um pequeno vídeo
de parte das técnicas que eu adquirir
com eles
E aí
e
os portugueses foram muito fortes na
nesta área na área do estuque
Principalmente os homens de afife oriosa
terras de Viana do Castelo coincidência
ou não a minha cidade que no século 18
desceram para Porto e Lisboa e fizeram
parte De
construíram e que fizeram parte de
construir imensos palácios e casas
privadas e a maior parte do espólio de
estuque Nacional foram que foi
construído por eles e
e quantos estucadores
trabalham atualmente
exclusivamente parte de estuque
quase neon neste preciso momento eu
conheço um e mesmo assim não
exclusivamente para a arte do estuque
Ele trabalha também quase setenta por
cento trabalhos ela é restauro foi então
quando eu já estava
há cinco anos nesta tela empresa de
gessos decorativos comecei a fazer
algumas visitas aos ateliers
destes educadores e alguns já reformados
para
conversar para poder partilhar para
poder absorver um pouco da das histórias
deles
nem este é um bocadinho estranho quando
eu entra uma rapariga nesta altura e e
diz que está a fazer exatamente o mesmo
que eles Oi e aí que quer por novamente
o estuco no mercado e valorizar a
eles ficaram logo pé trás quer dizer
impossível de fazer um mês que nós
fazemos esta dúvida
Terminou quando os convidei essas vamos
ver aqui uma partilha uma espécie de
intercâmbio primeiro filho lá conversei
e depois vieram eles o meu atelier
até com alguns eu consegui fazer alguns
trabalhos algumas parcerias
aqui uma troca a partilha de gerações
que é realmente aquilo que mais me
importava e E foi com quem com quem eu
tenho vindo aprender imenso
neste momento o que se passa é que estes
estucador especialmente os reformados
vem de uma geração de famílias dos
pescadores são filhos e netos dos
pecadores e os filhos deles não estão a
dar continuidade a arte e eles se
sentissem que morreu
aquilo nas nessas conversas nestas
visitas que que pretendia com ele era
diários entender que não está morrer e
que eu quero voltar a pôr no mercado
o que se passa é que te dá um ano para
trás eu tenho vindo a receber
o espólio que eles têm eles acham que
querem entregar
os bolsos
algumas peças em mãos de alguém que vê
continuidade e que Preserve de certa
forma o que estão a ver uma fotografia
de um bocadinho de um espólio que eu
recebi eu tenho que subir imensas coisas
neste momento
Ah
eu não sei não eu não sei o que quero
fazer
está guardado no meu atelier como todo o
carinho e quem vai com toda a certeza
para já servir de inspiração para os
meus trabalhos
talvez do futuro eu consiga
criar fazer uma homenagem a Estas
pessoas
com um arquivo ou uma espécie de eu não
gosto muito de chamar Museu mas um
espaço da exposição meritório para todo
o trabalho que eles fizeram esta a minha
vontade é voltar ao posto no mercado
obrigado
E aí